bonsoir messieurs et merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur ft france est ce que
c'est une réelle déconvenue au plan
médical et ce qu'on comptait vraiment
sur ce traitement bruno megaman
antiviral cavell avantage pour wall
et chris cris par les médecins
généralistes est venu en pharmacie de
ville
donc effectivement il comportait un
certain espoir
sachant évidemment
indiqué chez les personnes à haut risque
de faire une forme grave de la maladie à
condition qu'il soit prescrite dans les
trois à cinq jours après le la
contamination donc évidemment le groupe
de patients qu'ils pouvaient temps
politiciens étaient malgré tout limité
aux politiques alain houpert le
gouvernement est allé trop vite en
besogne tacler finalement par la haute
autorité de santé
je crois que ce gouvernement n'a ni qui
fait n'importe quoi vous souvenez il ya
eu l'épisode du rnd sivir le 28 le 8
octobre dernier et ça c'était la
commission européenne et
est ensuite quelques jours après on est
revenu en arrière mais l'europe a acheté
des des milliers ou de voir des millions
de doses et de le 26 octobre dernier le
ministre de la santé a rencontré le mot
lui pire à lire comme un remède miracle
il m'annonce tu es devant le sénat à la
livre et au début décembre de 50 mille
deux cent cinquante mille doses ses 35
millions d'euros 35 millions d'euros
c'est le salaire mensuel de 20000
soignants en début de carrière c'est pas
n'importe quoi donc je pense que ce
gouvernement
travaille à un petit peu au doigt
mouillé et je me pose la question de
savoir comment un gouvernement
commandé 50 mendoza médicaments sans
avoir obtenu de résultats scientifiques
seulement par une publicité d'un
laboratoire particulier à jorhat heures
m et sans se reposer sur la haute
autorité de santé alors qui dans
revendiquent-ils 102,8 en permanence et
là la haute autorité de santé has a
vraiment accule ministre de la santé
alors revenons si vous le voulez bien
bruno m'égare balle sur ce traitement
qu'est ce qu'il promettait très
concrètement et et c'était un traitement
qui s'est ajouté à la vaccination
d'appel on a un peu de mal à comprendre
son utilité et à qui il était réellement
destiné et dans quels cas très
concrètement
c'est un traitement antiviral qui va
limiter la multiplication du virus si
les prix en phase précoce de la maladie
donc dans les cinq jours suivant la
contamination alors les l'étude qui a
été fait par le laboratoire sur un un
échantillon relativement faible de
patients 1400 patient semblait montrer
dans un premier temps qu'au moins 50% de
il y avait 50% de réduction du risque de
développer une forme grave voire un
décès à la suite de la contamination
chez des personnes donc ayant un haut
risque de faire une forme grave de la
maladie ensuite on va dire lorsqu'ils
ont augmenté leur nombre de patients il
semble que ce pourcentage
le succès a été un tout petit peu réduit
à prendre pour cent malgré tout les
raisons pour lesquelles la chasse n'a
pas donné d'autorisation
c'est qu'elle a estimé dans cette
population de personnes à haut risque de
faire une forme grave de la maladie il
existait des traitements plus efficaces
ce sont les anticorps monoclonaux
anti spike
typiquement celui qu'a pris le président
trump qui sont aujourd'hui disponibles
en france et qui eux s'accompagne d'un
succès de l'ordre de 80 à 90% donc ils
ont estimé que si mes patients prenez ce
traitement qui ne marcherait que dans 30
à 50% des cas eh bien il se verrait
privée d'un traitement plus efficace
d'où la raison
de la non autorisation et
l'autorité de santé demande probablement
des études complémentaires mais on sait
évidemment dans toutes les études
présentées par les laboratoires au
départ on peut surestimer l'efficacité
parce qu'en fait on sélectionne de façon
drastique les patients et quand on vient
à faire l'étude en vie réelle c'est à
dire avec les patients habituel avec le
retard de diagnostic avec les formes un
peu plus variable de la maladie avec un
diagnostic parfois incertains avec des
comorbidités dont on tient pas compte eh
bien les résultats d'efficacité sont
toujours inférieurs les études vont donc
se poursuivre ce qui signifie que ce
n'était pas un refus définitif de la
part de la haute autorité de santé la
france était donc positionné pour
accueillir cinquante mille doses de ce
traitement beaulieu pira virale a ouvert
vous évoquez la facture à hauteur de 35
millions d'euros alors le ministère de
la santé a indiqué que je le cite la
nature du contrat prévoient un
déclenchement des commandes à un
déclenchement des commandes uniquement
en cas d'autorisation précoce de
déploiement qu'est ce que ça signifie
que finalement cette ardoise et ben il
est encore pas payer et donc la france
n'a pas perdu d'argent
j'espère une copie j'espérais et en tant
que parlementaire nous poserons la
question au ministre et je constate que
c'est encore un effet d'annoncé sauver
les meubles et je retiendrai ce que qu'a
dit mon beau frère le professeur me
garbade la fin parce que je parlerai pas
des chiffres simplement que la haute
autorité de santé refus de ce traitement
en avançant qu'il est moins efficace que
lors des autres traitements comme la
ville au nord à gardanne les anticorps
monoclonaux
bon on est dans une politique au doigt
mouillé où on va dans tous les sens on
fait des états d'anor l'effet d'annoncé
on est à quelques mois d'une élection
présidentielle
on voit tous les ministres tir détourné
d'hiver ouvre parce que il ya comme une
échéance importante qu'il faut
absolument que ce gouvernement soit
efficace face à cette pandémie et je
rappellerai à mon confrère le docteur
mais bekerman que contrairement à ce
qu'il affirmait à part avant que le
virus ne change pas de route devant les
personnes vaccinées et là maintenant
nous en avons la preuve il disait aussi
que le pass anitele retour à une liberté
sur et envoie aujourd'hui qu'il n'en est
rien quel regard que vous portez
aujourd'hui vous de votre côté médecin
que vous êtes bruno bécard balle sur la
stratégie sanitaire du gouvernement
écoutez pour moi il était tout à fait on
va dire
pertinent que le gouvernement réserve un
certain nombre de doses de ce médicament
dans la tente comme ça a été expliquée
des résultats et l'accord des autorités
sanitaires avant de le payer alors il
faut quand même souligner les avantages
que présente ce médicament par rapport à
ceux disponibles actuellement c'est un
médicament que l'on pouvait prendre par
voie orale
prescrit par le médecin de ville
des livrables en pharmacie de ville et
donc évidemment il est beaucoup plus
simple à administrer que les anticorps
monoclonaux
qui nécessitent une hospitalisation du
jour pour être administré par voie
intraveineuse ou intra musculaire et on
voit bien d'ailleurs la difficulté de
d'administrer ces anticorps monoclonaux
fait que beaucoup de stocks sont encore
présents dans les hôpitaux et non
utilisées alors le deuxième intérêt on
va dire de ces médicaments c'est que ce
sont des médicaments qui ne concerne pas
la protéine spike il concerne
langil qui est impliqué dans la
réplication de la rn et donc sous
entendu ils peuvent être actif malgré
les mutations et les variations que qui
surviennent sur la protéine spike
contrairement aux anticorps monoclonaux
qui pourrait par exemple avec le variant
omikron perdre totalement leur
efficacité donc il ya bien quelques
avantages qui justifiait l'intérêt des
autorités sanitaires pour ces antiviraux
mais évidemment on l'a dit aujourd'hui
les résultats d'efficacité était
extrêmement limitée et surtout bien sur
l'évaluation des effets secondaires
quasi inexistante on sait que c'est un
médicament à risque de créer des
mutations il est content indiqué chez la
femme enceinte
les effets secondaires en population
réelle de patients qui prennent d'autres
médicaments sont inconnus et dont
évidemment il fallait extrêmement
prudent d'ailleurs nos reines des civils
qui a été préconisé prises précédemment
pour traiter la commune 19
malheureusement s'est révélé être
il efficace est ce que la recherche d'un
traitement efficace je vous comprenez
mégarde mais je voudrais vous poser la
question avoue alain houpert comment
est-ce que vous expliquiez que la
recherche d'un traitement efficace
évolue plus lentement beaucoup plus
lentement visiblement que celle des
vagues ce
jeudi que le le gouvernement est dans
les cordes du gouvernement a besoin de
trouver une solution parce que la
stratégie du gouvernement le vaccin
seuls n'est pas bonne donc il faut
absolument trouver des traitements nous
en avons vous parliez du remdh et sévir
tout à l'heure c'est quand même 2100
euros la dose
il faut raison garder ça c'est une
pandémie qui certes peut tuer mais tu
peux de personnes et moi je signerai
autre docteur müller 20 ans tant que
parlementaire ça nous sommes
auscultés par la haute autorité de
transparence
parlementaires et les médecins doivent
déclarer leurs conflits d'intérêts et en
tant que ça je n'ai aucun compte rien et
je ne lis pas le mode d'emploi d'un
médicament ou d'un laboratoire et au
sénat nous avons auditionné il ya
quelques quelques jours à la demande de
la droite sénatoriale des soignants qui
révèle un hôpital public en ruine et
c'est ça le gros problème de cette
épidémie et le ségur de la santé n'a
rien changé à ce malaise structurel et
on n'a pas donné la possibilité aux
médecins la liberté pas prescrire et on
leur a
engagé des procès d'intention
je signale donc
il ya une maladie non kozun nocosomiales
dans l'hôpital ce tte la structure la
technostructure est en train de tuer
l'hôpital nous avons deux mille cinq
cents personnes en réanimation
alors qu'ils nous annoncent sekera hier
je vous ai perdu bon quel est ce que
vous faites pardon avec le mot nucléaire
c'est un deus makina % le gouvernement
de la seule stratégie vaccinale qui ne
marche pas tout derniers mois avec vous
bruno megaman et ce sera le mot de la
fin vous vous confirmez vous êtes en
accord avec ces propos la seule
stratégie vassal ne fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui
alors je voudrais quand même vraiment
mettre en doute tous les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus c'est scandaleux
de parler comme ça j'allais dire la la
la la crise qu vide a quand même entré
demi million de spitz alisation la
mortelle le décès de 120000 personnes
dire que c'est une maladie pas grave
qu'il n'y a eu aucune morbi-mortalité
c'est scandaleux
la vaccination a parfaitement fonctionné
aujourd'hui nous vivons quasi
normalement grâce aux découplages qui se
fait entre les contaminations qui certes
progressent et les hospitalisations qui
reste relativement contenu enfin laisser
penser que un médecin comme moi à des
conflits d'intérêts lorsqu'il parle et
explique les la maladie et sa gravité
c'est également purement scandaleux
eh bien écoutez on aura l'occasion de
poursuivre ce débat malheureusement le
temps nous manque merci à tous les deux
à l'heure où père sénateurs les
républicains de cawdor merci à vous
bonhommes et gardanne chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris